möchte münchen familie und mein gott wie
knuffig die möchte am liebsten direkt
essen
[Musik]
hallo ich meine lieben frauen und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde
minecraft ps minecraft pocket edition
hier auf meinem kanal
ich hab das ganze gerade in einer zeit
von einer halben stunde irgendwie
versucht auch zunehmend in welchen
kabeln und auf dem pc umzuleiten auf dem
fernseher über hdmi und alles möglich
ist neben klopp
deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade das
stativ beim einer canon auf dem schoß so
halbwegs das geht nur durch meinen stuhl
rum geben folgt die konstruktion gar
nicht sehen die hier gerade aufgebaut
habe nur um das hier aufnehmen zu können
und das ist wahrscheinlich sogar im
moment sieht richtig kaka aus wald man
sieht halt meine finger ich schau dir
mal so ab und zu wenig leiser werden
heißt dass ich so ein bisschen auf meine
auf die kamera über mir schau auf dem
bildschirm messi kaka aus weil ich meine
finger total im bild habe ich habe es
nicht hingekriegt irgendwie umzuleiten
habt ihr gegen die empfehlung für mich
dass ich sachen aufnehmen kann ich hab
ja schon mal links aufgenommen
wann war das denn damals noch mal was
heißt denn damals noch aufgenommen
irgendwas über alf lady bird genau das
habe ich damals schon aufgenommen das
habe ich auch so ähnlich gemacht jetzt
so finde ich ist sogar noch ein bisschen
besser ist gerade zwar keine fans kam
aber hallo ihr seht meine hände also das
ist ja wohl genug und ich habe gedacht
ich spiele einfach mal eine runde aller
schweine runde minecraft ihn nicht weil
ich da so unglaublich viele bottroper
haben sondern weil mir dass die leute
geschrieben haben doch mal ein graffiti
das ist doch ganz witzig und ich bin
jetzt gerade in creative motto in der
welt erstellt ich kann einfach hierhin
tippen mal ganz groß und die steuerung
klarzustellen
und dann kann ich jetzt gebäude hin
bauen oder 8
später einen kleinen penis tierisch lag
ich nämlich einfach drauf ich tue das
schwein jetzt mal was kann mich an
betonen schon mal kurz den ton an
vielleicht hört man da was
man hört sogar ist oder ich weiß gar
nicht von der seite oder ob jeder haus
gehört ja doch so ein bisschen sollte zu
hören sein
ok ich kann jetzt hier gedrückt hat dann
kann ich hier so nach oben fliegen aber
ich finde creative ist langweilig habe
jetzt angedacht kommen so viele wollen
das immer ich denke immer so nein die
welten sind so klein
jetzt gibt es unendlich große welten in
seinem update auch kummer es gibt sogar
schnee wie schafe alter wie viele schon
gearbeitet haben die sterben gp kleine
schafe wenn es euch nicht interessiert
könnt ihr weg scheint noch vielem einig
soll das mal spielen weil viele keinen
pc anzuschauen oder meinen sogar spiel
mal pipi
das ist auch ganz geil ich rutsche immer
was ein bisschen aus dem bild mit tut
mir sehr sehr lieb ich bin mal peters
auch sega ich komme der steuerung noch
nicht so gut klar
wir gehen mal ganz kurz für kvitova zum
titel machen uns mal eine neue welt im
survival creighton uns mal und dann
schauen wir mal wie das ganze spielt
sich das eigentlich nicht ist gar nicht
gut
schauen wir mit ich das ganze dann aber
die herzen kann ich schon sprinten
was ist das ja ok auch keine ahnung
spenden kann ich auf jeden fall nicht
ich wollte mal von einer treppe
runterfallen mal schauen was passiert
also ja wahrscheinlich bin ich tot aber
ach guck mal das ist auch cool ich muss
einfach gegen den block gegen lauffen
moment und dann hüpft er das
automatische das cool ich fahre man hier
runter einfach kommen und sogar die
süßen alten minecraft sonst noch und
machen wir uns erstmal kurzen bett so
ein wohlhabender mann nicht rutscht im
außenbild luca bleibt jetzt mal genau so
genau so bleibe ich jetzt wird
guck mal die blumen gibt das ist komisch
mit dem update man kann auch nicht
doppelt spricht man kann nicht schnell
laufen aber nein man kann nicht schnell
laufen aber es gibt schon diese komische
blüten hier
naja die will ich weg bin ich ja auch
ein paar hallo baby schwein okay für
mich aber stört sperma droppen die
kleinen eigentlich auch schon irgendwie
fleisch oder so kraft müssen wir nochmal
also ist das erste mal dass das spiel
ich habe gerade unter gelernt was steht
da so dass nur eine birke ach guck mal
da hin sind auch schnitte coole naja
kommen wir direkt hier kommen wir uns
erst mal hier bei den den blöden beugen
hier ist muss erst ein bisschen holz
dann gleich zu den cooleren gebirge gab
es nicht auch mal so ein kreis der
eigentlich dann voll wurde wenn man
gerade einen blog fast abgebaut hat ist
das nicht auch mal und jetzt gibt es das
schon diese animation drin
ist schon vieles neues dazugekommen ich
möchte eigentlich nur eine kleine hütte
bauen und dann war's das auch schon dann
wollte ich euch fragen ob er eventuell
möglichkeiten auch dass ich das öfters
aufnehmen kann und dann eventuell auch
unter etwas anderen perspektive weil
dann würde ich eventuell auch mal in
dieser auf der mobile version würde ich
dann hier eventuell auch mal weg machen
bei dem wir werden so viel effekt
zugesendet über die mobile version also
nicht über die mobile version sondern
die so über die mobile version handeln
und da denke ich mir mal so ja aber ich
kann ja schlecht aufnehmen deswegen wenn
die tipps abschalten einfach dass es so
war der einzige grund warum ich dieses
video machte so ich habe zuerst ein
bisschen holz jetzt mache ich mal so
ah so man jetzt klicke ich die an
ich möchte mir gerne crafting titel
machen und vier sticks so das ist aber
alles relativ simpel
also wenn man minecraft schon mal
gespielt hat kann man sich das auf jeden
fall von selbst erklären
guck mal ich hab übrigens toolan zumute
hier gemacht soll ich dir mal an mit
soll in seinem coolen havana club glas
das wundervoll der schmeckt richtig gut
da sollte man gut vielleicht manchmal
kochen tutorial das kochen wäsche was
essen der stadt
so spreche derzeit vieles auf die
antwort ist einfach weil ich mir zur
zeit wenn man die ganzen alten videos
gebe weil ja so etwas hochlädt und das
mit dem spring backt noch mal nicht mal
so wir laufen dass man nach vorne
schauen die sonne liegen allerdings
unter also wären gerade mit einem tag
ich würde sagen wenn die nacht anbricht
schaue mal waren die ersten mops kommen
und dann wachsen
oh mein gott wie knuffig die mutter mit
ihren kindern vor wie süß guck mal wie
viele dir auch so dass man blumen ja gut
wie knöpfe ich guck mal die laufende
mutter hinterher
ich möchte am liebsten direkt essen
[Musik]
gerne dass meine meinung wie sie ist
können wir eine minute mit den münchen
da beschäftigt das gut so
treppen möchte mir nicht machen ich
möchte meine kiste machen nämlich 2 was
möchtest dann darauf machen rüstung kann
ich guck mal da bin ich weiß nicht gibt
es das kind
das wäre so gut wenn ich das guck mal
die mögen mich richtig manchmal hier ein
bisschen ein bisschen boden nicht weil
meine schaufel machen stimmt das wollte
ich machen damit hier nämlich mit dem
graben kann
sonst kriegt hier
[Musik]
jetzt freue ich mich mal so ein paar
sachen ab damit ich hier auch hinziehen
kann
ich habe das gefühl hat uns ein wenig zu
laut oder wahrscheinlich ist genau
perfektem einer tonspur auf jeden fall
genau perfekt thematisch mit der
steuerung so es ist zwar eigentlich
super die steuerung nur ich musste ja so
blöd um dieses mikrofon um das stativ
pump halten ich mach gleich nochmal
meine face cam hier an vorne von dem
iphone
damit ihr seht wie ich hier gerade sitze
alter johnson richtig cool ist das cool
das will ich mir auch für dich wünschen
so daneben jetzt mal nämlich die axt von
fällen es doch mal ein paar von diesen
bäumen weil die sind cool münchen
bleiben echt hier das ist ja echt
schillig kommen wir den ball besser als
ein hallo fall steht der marwitzer sonst
gehe ich den ruf wenn ich treffe flop
abbauen
ich hoffe ihr seht also sie wird
wahrscheinlich hat nur einen
stinkefinger hier vorne
die ich aber noch keine bestnoten so
jetzt hier
hier soll doch hier bloggt und das
parkett auf dem boden das sollte sogar
genau passen alter also so war ich diese
wiener liebe so ein bisschen pony ich
hab' ich habe zwei zu wenig ab gefällt
sobald diese wieder liebe ein bisschen
ads haben sie ja schon da kommt der
kirche und da kann man die kiste ist das
wundervoll
hier kommt da rein das war meine 25 erde
können die nicht komplett allein tun
aber man kann es einfach gedrückthalten
alter es gibt es ein paar sachen die da
denke ich mir so geil das haben sie gut
gemacht
darf man schon mal eben mann angetroffen
habe ich zwei schaufeln egal ich habe
mir keine angst gemacht ich hab eine
schaufel gemacht kollegah schaffen sind
viel wichtiger auf den fall
es gebe also mache ich das ganze zeit
wieder schaufel ob lessing hat das auch
so lange gedauert das habe ich mich
schon gefragt hallo lange vom 3
doch klopp wo ist jetzt hier noch hallo
da jeder hinten kommt auch noch alle mit
ich will jetzt einfach mal langsam das
nacht wird dass irgendwo ein paar mob
zeigen kann oder ich denke ich hoffe mal
dass es welche gibt
weil ich hätte ich brauch hier so eine
kleine welt zu machen und irgendwie weiß
nicht so immer mehr nicht bespielt das
hier so ein bisschen jetzt nicht dass
wir sie jetzt sauer aber jetzt playhouse
wird oder so aber schon auf jeden fall
so ein paar jetzt hab ich das heute
alltag man jetzt passt kann ich den
falschen baum gefällt ja ist ja auch
egal ich brauche auf jeden fall noch
eine spitzhacke und spaten dafür war
erstmals klicks und jetzt eine
spitzhacke ein schwert und dann mache
ich mir jetzt noch mal steckt dann
machen wir akzeptieren das ganze ist
blöd dass ich nur fünf dinge unten
reinpacken kann
expertinnen darüber die spitzhacke und
da kommt da ach so eine axt habe ich
auch noch nicht so gerne
sondern es geht mal kurz auf mob jagte
also hier schon mal unser kleines berlin
ich will man erst mal prüfen so ruhig
habe ich habe gesagt ich fast ein
trottel
ich hoffe mal ihr seht noch alles ich
meine ich kann man auch noch keinen ofen
machen weil dafür bräuchte ja stein und
ich hab kein bock acht kommen das hat
mich ja kommen haben ja zeit hier
dann habe ich mich immer kurz runter und
holt gescher steine oder gar nicht
eingehen
doch alter meine movie aufnahme wurde
gerade automatisch angehalten ihr seht
noch da das skelett
ich bin gerade gestorben ich hoffe die
explosion ist drauf ich hoffe die
explosion ist drauf naja egal
ja gut das skelett backwerke hat so ein
bisschen rum
ich würde eigentlich wollte mir
eigentlich stein holen aber das war es
dann mit der ersten folge was heißt bei
der ersten folge mit dem video
der minecraft pocket edition wenn ihr
wisst ich mein iphone aufnehmen kann
damit die besten die nächsten videos
besser werden schreibt mir das in den
kommentaren
doch schnell so barbara stamm und dann
würde ich auf jeden fall sagen wir sehen
uns in dem anderen video wieder ist ein
bisschen blöd dass ich gestorben bin
wenn ich dann davon wirklich ein paar
videos machen würde würde ich mir eine
neue welt machen das ganze besser machen
und alles mögliche noch mich ein
bisschen mit der steuerung an freunde
heute mit der vestische von einer wespe
gestochen ein ganzes stück weg
das ist richtig richtig ekelhaft und ich
würde sagen es euch trotzdem gefallen
hat zeigt es mir mit einer bewertung und
wir sehen uns dann irgendwann wieder
ich bin tot ich hoffe ich hatte diese
prepaid version drauf mal schauen sonst
habt ihr so nicht gesehen egal